Oh Stephen Kelly is the chief executive
of the tech company sage which is behind
the report a very warm welcome to you
Stephen and let's start with the
positives then because you know let's
fly the flag for the country's
entrepreneurs they're doing very well
they appear to be resilient given the
kind of politics and the economic
backdrop that the country's facing a
moment yes is a bad thing they've got a
tremendous buccaneering spirit and we're
seeing some dazzling performance right
across the small business our report
highlights that three-quarters of all
the new jobs that's over 2 million jobs
since 2010 had been created by smaller
medium businesses so the the as you say
the engine room the economy the backbone
whatever analogy you want to use and
they're alive well and absolutely
focused on overcoming adversity as they
have done through the credit crunch and
creating jobs and prosperity right
across the UK ok so they're they're
alive and they're well but let's be
brutally honest productivity and growth
is poor nationally why
yeah the report today is almost A Tale
of Two Cities job creation fantastic but
a massive productivity issue and they're
driving in some cases with a handbrake
on and what we see is the disparity
highlights in terms of the data suggests
that is 26 times more productive in some
regions and local authorities than the
worst-performing and on average four
times more productive now in the bigger
context obviously we've got a
Productivity issue we're twenty nine
percent less productive than countries
like France so it is really something we
can boost prosperity not only thoroughly
but herbally as well we can bring
everybody up that's the point I mean it
is a rural incredibly rural area West
Somerset and it feels like you know it's
not a really fair comparison when you're
comparing it with say the City of London
you're never going to have a huge number
of productive entrepreneurs there are
usual no I think but the highlight and
the really big takeaways of the report
today shows the disparity right across
the UK with Northern Ireland which shows
a lot of factors not only in terms of
things like digital skills the education
system the propensity to export it
really drills down and shines a
spotlight and what it does do is very
clearly shout out that to really drive
productivity it's not one size fits all
because actually one
size fits no one its about local
solutions delivered locally so what did
we learn from this and we got a very
skewed economy essentially yeah and I
think it's very clear that we have a
skewed economy the data for the first
time today actually allows you to look
at point of view of policy for central
government for local authorities for MPS
to really join up and support through
the chambers of commerce the labs the
accountants the university and academic
system and where we see in the
productivity really drive forward it's
where the local partnerships are working
effectively I wonder you know you may
not agree but I wonder if you think that
however well-intentioned they are if it
in work benefits actually drive down
wages and actually encourage companies
to continue with low wages
well I can't repeat it yeah I think you
know again we're within representative
many of our customers that the customers
right across the UK fifty-three percent
of businesses in the UK usage to pay
their employees so I think we're not
only a champion but a pulse of where
they are and they pay their employees
well and they absolutely typically take
care not only their employees but they
play a bigger role in their community
that's why they're so vital to the
national interest I'm just finally can
it get better given the challenges that
we're facing as a country yeah I think
the small and medium businesses across
the UK are hugely optimistic the
entrepreneurs always overcome adversity
and they looking in the future for the
exporters because of the currency
devaluation they're doing incredibly
well Stephen Kelly great to talk to you
thanks very much indeed